people seem to be popping with a dead
space remake man yeah I'm a Dutch page
dude I love that game I just thought
that it took you know King and I had
this debate before but it just it took a
lot of the things that early Resident
Evil games did glow in the dark and it
applied it in a way where this is the
game that came after Resident Evil 4
right so Resident Evil 4 for some people
was able to walk that line of like you
still have horror elements that work but
it was more action-y but the horror came
more from the tension of all of these
enemies coming at you at once in a way
that didn't happen in the old games
whereas Dead Space took some of that put
you back in into an enclosed environment
and then try to go back to the true sort
of the horror of it of like jump scares
and you know crazy the environments that
are small and but wow giving you the
better control than a Resident Evil 4 so
now you were empowered but they were
still finding ways to scare you right